il aimait bien tout ce qui est aquarium
poisson donc on en a aussi la moto ça il
était un grand femme de moto il partait
aussi en weekend avec des amis faire des
en moto il aimait bien la pêche aussi et
bah il aimait bien aussi le boulot aller
travailler il rechignait pas il allit
toujours avec le
S ça pas beaucoup changé sauf que
quelques petits coup de blouse qu'il
peut avoir de temps en temps beaucoup de
douleur aussi qu'on peut ressentir dans
le regard la position qu'il peut avoir
aussi mais sinon toujours souriant
affectueux aussi làdessus ça a pas
changé après pour quelques passion comme
la moto bah malheureusement c'est
fini ce jour-là je me rappelle très bien
c'est un dimanche donc on était parti
faire les magasins je reçois un coup de
fil de mon beau-père en voiture donc je
mets sur le côté je je je décroche et
c'est là qu' m'a appris Queen avait eu
un accident on l'a vu assez tard on l'a
vu le lundi matin très tôt allonger donc
sur le moment le temps de le voir pas
vraiment de réaction et puis on
s'approchait bah moi j'ai fondu en larme
le fait de le voir allonger d'habitude
c'est toujours quelqu'un qui rigole qui
énergique et là allongé sur un lit
entubé attaché au lit aussi donc c'était
pas c'est un moment assez difficile ça
arrive pas qu'X autres malheureusement
on dit toujours ça peut arriver ça
arrive qu'aux autres ça perturbe toute
une famille en
fait ça pas été tous les jours facile
non plus de voir Aurélien comme ça c'est
contraignant et tout mais après avec
l'amour aussi on arrive à à passer outre
l'handicap comme on dit ça reste une
personne comme nous sauf qu'il a pas ses
jambes
quoi